okay so now we have an idea for a
different algorithm
and it's going to be based off of an
approach called branch and bound so
let's learn a little bit about this and
i'm going to give a really hazy
vague overview of what a branch and
bound algorithms idea is
okay so you're going to start with a
simple candidate solution and you're
going to expand it
or branch that out into different
solutions and then you might
do this again and then after you've
branched out into a number of possible
solutions or
small seeds of larger possible solutions
then you're going to say okay can we
exclude any of those can we eliminate
any of these
candidate solutions that we have and
that's called the bound step
all right so we from here to here we've
eliminated five solutions
and we're left with these are not
necessarily solutions but they're at
least
candidates for solutions at the leaves
of this tree
then we say okay let's branch again
and then we'll need to bound based off
of some condition we'll exclude
some of these edges when we move from
branch to bound
and now we have maybe some candidate
solutions and we can go ahead and test
these
so we've found a way of eliminating
certain solutions
before we construct them so we want to
apply the same idea to
eliminating some candidate peptides
before they ever get generated
all right so let's apply it to
cyclopeptide sequencing then
here's a possible spectrum all right
and our first question is which amino
acids
have masses in the spectrum so if we
look at bring back this integer mass
table
then we highlight p has mass 97 and it
occurs in the spectrum v has mass 99 it
occurs in the spectrum
we also get t and c
so we're going to start with four one
more peptides
all right we're going to start with just
these single amino acids
what we're going to do is we're going to
extend these four into all possible
tumor peptides so all possible amino
acid strings of length two
so we get p a v a t a and c a we get p c
v
c t c and c c and so on
all right so we started with four and
we're going to
now multiply that by 18 because we're
adding each possible amino acid
onto each of these four and we're left
with 72.
so we want to know how we can trim this
list right so we've done our branch step
and now we need to do our bound step and
bring it back
so to do this trimming we'll notice that
pv is what's called
consistent with spectrum here's one
possible tumor and it's
you'll notice that the mass of p is
equal to 97
it's present the mass of v the other
letter
in pv is present as 99 and the mass of
this entire
small linear peptide pv is 196 and it's
also
detected so that's called consistent if
you when you chop up
this candidate solution and weigh its
its fragments that all those fragments
are found in the spectrum
cd is one that we actually created in
the expand step
but it's inconsistent with the spectrum
so although 103 the mass of c
is present is detected 115 and 218
the mass of d and the mass of the entire
tumor peptide cd
they're not found you can't find 115 or
218 in this spectrum
so we want to exclude cd and
after we do this step and we figure out
what it is that we need to trim we're
left with
10 amino acid strings of length 2. from
our 72 we've cut it down to 10.
so let's do the exact same thing let's
expand each of these in
all 18 possible directions we'll get now
180 different
threamer peptides and then let's check
whether or not
each one is consistent and we'll trim it
down after we do this
we go from 180 to 15
and we say okay this is going well we're
preventing these
peptides from growing crazy crazily and
so we expand them and then we'll trim so
we go from 15
and do 15 times 18 so we get 270 and
then we find which of those 270 formers
are consistent with the spectrum and
we're down to 10.
we do it one more time expand and then
trim
and we're left with ten consistent five
mers all right
and you can verify that if each of these
each of these is corresponds to the
exact same cyclic peptide
and the spectrum of eat of this cyclic
peptide coincides exactly with our
experimental spectrum
so now we have a method that's going to
work and it looks like it's going to be
pretty efficient i'll just summarize
what it is
we find all the amino acids whose masses
occur in the spectrum
and we add them to a list then we extend
uh every peptide that's currently in the
list
in every possible direction so in we add
each
of 18 different amino acid masses onto
the end of it and then we have this trim
step where we say
let's take which of these are
inconsistent and let's just get rid of
them
then we'll return any peptides whose
theoretical spectra
match the experimental spectrum that
we're given and we'll do
steps two two through four over and over
again this branching and bounding and
then testing
until we run out of peptides to consider
until we
have all inconsistent peptides
so we we've seen it works really well on
an on an example but
we ask ourselves whether or not this
algorithm is efficient in practice
so the brute force algorithm that we saw
before it was exponential and by
exponential i mean
if you look at its input size the number
of steps that it has to take or the
number in this case the number of
peptides that it has to consider
grows exponentially with respect to the
input size
it may be true that the branch and bound
algorithm that we've come up with
is exponential on some data set like
somewhere way out in the galaxy you can
form some data set
that it takes a really really long time
to to run and it's prohibitive
but in practice it's actually really
fast so
it looks like we're done and uh we can
have a party and go home
that's the question though can we really
and i'm gonna have to pop that balloon
and say no